I don't really know how to do the sort
of prep stuff without it being somewhat
intensive because otherwise I just don't
feel I have the confidence I always
imagine that I'm going to get to set and
the director is going to go I don't even
like this scene
make it up and I've got to be ready for
that and if I'm not ready for that I
feel very insecure arriving on the set
[Music]
American Psycho
[Music]
new card
what do you think
very nice
look at that picked them up from the
printers yesterday good coloring that's
bone any scene we would do in every
single day I had the book by my side and
I would read through it every single
time because Brett had just had so many
wonderful descriptions and I think that
was why Mary and I clicked was because
when I first went and auditioned for her
I just went to her apartment and it was
just her with a little camera and I I
didn't approach it like she said the
other actors had where they were talking
about what's his childhood what's the
reason he's become this I was like ah
none of that really matters he's just
like this alien and so as we were doing
the scene I started laughing
and she started cracking up and we both
realized we had the same very sick sense
of humor and we were like oh yeah all
right this will work between us she
really put herself on the line you know
and I so appreciate that because she had
so many known actors who who were
stepping up and wanted to do it and she
just said no I want Christian even
though all the financiers were saying
we're going to give you no money and
then actually kicked the two of us off
uh you know we went and we did a stage
reading in New York for it uh William
Defoe was there Chloe 70 was there and
Brace and Ellis was there and then we
got the money yay but what our agents
forgot to do our agents at the time uh
forgot to do was to include us in the
package and so we raised the money and
then they said right and the two of you
bye-bye but um I I went a little bit
psycho myself in that and I just said
well no I'm still making the film and
even though other people were cast other
directors were on board I just kept on
prepping and I would call Mary up and
she would say Christian they've given it
to other people I was like yeah yeah no
it doesn't matter what still going to
make it and she was like oh he's lost
the plot and all my friends were saying
that to me like what are you doing and I
was turning down it wasn't like I was
getting offered much but you know a
couple of projects not very good ones I
turned them down and kept on going and
lo and behold look at that it did
eventually come back so that felt like a
great Victory don't doubt you got
instincts you know I always listen
always be aware of the style that the
director is looking for but understand
you're always going to bring something
unique from anybody else when there
still was the Wall Street trading floors
and everything I went and visited you
know all different levels of people at
Wall Street but the guys on the trading
floor when I arrived there before making
the film I got there and a bunch of them
they were going oh Patrick Bateman and
Pat me on the back and go oh yeah we
love him and I was like yeah ironically
right and they were like what do you
mean so it was always worrying um even
back then but you know clearly look it's
a satire on capitalism in the 80s and as
such is is so bloody far-fetched and
ridiculous the you know to me I can't
help but think it's hilarious
[Music]
it's the release of their 1980 album
Duke I'm not going to ruin anyone's
enjoyment and say that I'm not a huge
fan and they're not life-changing songs
of course they are for everyone right
come on when you admit it for me it's a
music's so much a part of actually
building characters as well you know
like for Amsterdam David and I were
listening to them and watching a lot of
jazz documentaries Etc and I use all
sorts of different uh music to help me
you know get into the mood when I'm
working because emotion really comes
through the ears you know something that
you notice when you're in the edit room
you really see how you can see the
visual
keep that the same but change the music
and it absolutely changes the way you
feel about it so it's such a you know a
joy of Life get a goddamn job
stopping you I remember somebody
threatening me on the street because
some people did object to the film
getting made and all that and I remember
people saying that they were going to do
me harm and stuff like that you know and
I would actually go like I don't know if
it's somebody somebody wanted me must
have been a friend of mine who was crazy
early on the internet and they warned me
they called me up and they went there's
some person and they know where you walk
every single day and you go down this
back alley and they say that they're
going to jump on you and they're going
to rip your cerebral cortex out of your
head so please don't go down that alley
so of course I was like I'm going to
that alley I want to see what happens
unfortunately nothing I kept walking up
and down here going where are they come
on
nothing ever happened
Batman
[Music]
a weirdo right jumping around
town at night in a bad outfit in many
ways in the same way that people were
telling me hey you can't go play Patrick
Bateman it's career suicide and I was
like Bring it on I definitely want to do
that other people also said hey you know
if you play Batman that's it you're
never going to play anything else again
you will always be Batman and I went
Bring It On Let's see if that happens
because I just always felt like look if
I don't have the skill to be able to
rise above that then I don't deserve to
either I absolutely know and cherish the
fact that that will be the role I'm
probably remembered for most you know
every is an iconic you know Larger than
Life
um uh role but I don't view it really as
old being stopped in the street for me
it was ah I could pay off my house
that's a huge relief you know that was a
dream of mine since being a kid so I
really appreciate that I think Chris
Nola no end for that you know the
experience of actually working with him
of course and we went on to make you
know four films together but the fact
that that allowed me to make so many
other films you know for instance it
took Mary a Herculean effort which I so
appreciate to get me cast in American
Psycho post Batman it got a little bit
easier for directors to suggest me and
finance use to say okay yeah we'll take
him you've got the wounded child who
never moved on from the atrocity and
tragedy that happens to him and he loses
his parents and then the kind of monster
that represents you know all this anger
and that he you know concentrates
focuses into this character of uh the
Batman and then the kind of charade
which is the the Playboy apparently
vacant and that no one would ever
suspect of having any beliefs or causes
ever in his life most of my recollection
of making Batman is sitting doing
crosswords by myself in a blue tent with
very uncomfortable stuff on because they
want to be ready in 15 minutes at any
given go so I was always sitting there
and these things going uh four down
hello is anyone out there
Heath Ledger who oh my God you know what
a performance what a pleasure to have
gotten to work with him and just to see
him you know and how much he put himself
into the Joker and I would and I was
watching it going yeah this is
absolutely fantastic are we in trouble
here of when Chris and I first sat down
we said you're not the problem but
Batman is is that the villains are
always more interesting right and so
Batman actually he's very close to being
a villain himself so let's never let him
become dull by comparison and
unfortunately I was sitting there going
I'm feeling a little bit dull by
comparison because Heath is just like
killing this and but I'm so proud of
that film I love it that the Dark Knight
is absolutely extraordinary you know and
it was such a pleasure to have gone away
with ease I don't want to kill you what
would I do without you go back to
ripping off mob dealers no no
no no you
you a complete me you're garbage you
kills for money don't talk like one of
them you're not
even if you'd like to be he was a
wonderful um go-kart driver a racer yeah
we went we went and raced the go-karts
and holy crap he'd be all the stunt guys
and everything he was quick when we went
to the track we thought of course the
stunt guys are going to win and there's
suddenly Heath wins
gets top place and then very quietly
mentions you know my dad was a go-kart
racer very talented individual and a
great soul to be around yeah I miss him
crazy
The Fighter
[Music]
Vicky he's such a character like he
makes his presence felt all the time I
mean I spent so much time hanging out
with Dickie beforehand and still in
touch and still in touch with Dickie Jr
being in Lowell hanging out with him
going walking around getting kicked out
of bars having almost every cop stopping
and going hey hey Dicky and then telling
me about a story about when they
arrested him going to the boxing gym
jumping in the ring and sparring with
him and oh my God it's really quite
something when you you might think you
can ah I'll be a decent boxer Spa with
other amateurs and whatnot I've done
that a few times but when you get in the
ring with a pro bloody hell do I
remember one time he was sitting and he
was reading the script and I was busy
doing something else and suddenly I see
him like stand up and he starts walking
over to David like oh and I could see
you know something had happened and I
went weed this ain't good and jumped
over and said dicky dicky dicky what and
just kind of talked him down because it
was about sort of you know hey look when
you tell someone's story you go don't
sell the good stuff and you've got to
tell the bad stuff otherwise there ain't
no story there at all it was the first
film that I've made with David and so
getting to understand this process more
and then and then he's kind of enhanced
that as we've made more films together
and I loved it I loved playing a Dickie
so much there were hilarious things and
there was you know stuff to do with just
sort of almost being shut down by the
local cops and things like that but to
me that's all part of the fun of it
there's a machinist
you okay
don't I look okay
right when I turned that was really
stand at how much weight I'd lost he
went oh you really did it like he didn't
think I really was going to that was
just a the outward show of his guilt and
being eaten alive literally you know by
guilt I'd come off of making a couple of
films that I've been less than satisfied
with and just really wanted something
where I could become immersed and
obsessed with it you know I mean I
remember at the time it was like not the
smart thing to do because there was no
money in it and it was like oh bloody
I'm gonna lose my place where I'm living
and I was quite newly married and all
that so it wasn't the business smart
thing to do but I've never been Smart in
a business way but it was something that
I really wanted to challenge myself and
kind of see could I achieve that could I
fulfill how I imagined that the part of
Trevor should be played
um you know and testing myself
perfect fit
a lot of times actually I would sit
there with headphones in but I wasn't
listening to anything I was just
pretending to listen so that I could
actually hear everything that was going
on but nobody thought I could also at
the time I was engaged in a very filthy
habit of smoking so I was rolling my own
cigarettes and sitting there puffing
away I did read numerous things I
remember because the conversation with
Brad the director I was I read crime and
punishment but then I was reading a lot
lighter Fair as well the main point was
that somehow losing all the physical
weight put all the energy into my brain
and so I only slept two hours a night
and all I wanted to do was read and so I
would just sit and read endlessly and I
found that I could read without stopping
and needing to move or get a distraction
I could I could just sit and read for 10
hours straight without moving a muscle
yeah I can't do that now
The Big Short
I've been very clear
people will withdraw their money
if if if the fund's capitals drop too
much
then the swaps contracts are avoided and
then the banks uh get to keep all of
them wait a minute wait all of it what
the contract's avoided
the contract's avoided I had a wonderful
day where we sat in his darkened office
together and just chatted and they had
scheduled all these things for us to go
out and about and do different stuff and
we ended up doing none of that because
we just enjoyed talking with each other
so much and had just an extraordinary
day and he was so helpful and then he
came to visit the set and then you know
we keep in touch from time to time and
he's an extraordinarily special guy wow
what a role you know so my first time
working with Adam which I just loved you
know he's he's something else you know
it's like with David you know when you
get really great directors they're very
unique uh in in the way that they work
[Music]
anyone who plays drums can look and go
Christian doesn't play drums but that to
me was not the point the point was not
that Michael burry was a shith drummer
it was that he took his anger out on
these drums and I did I was just
shattering the drumsticks they were
flying across the crew had to all put
Shields up because so many of them were
flying at speed everybody I love to get
to interview people I love to get to
really study them in an obsessive way
that you wouldn't get to usually that's
part of the joy of of the job for me
Vice
[Music]
a sense that
you're a kinetic leader you make
decisions based on instinct
I am people I said that yeah yeah very
different very different from
from your father in that regard all
right let's dig a bit deeper and go
do the very unlikely thing of me play
Dick Cheney which I was like what Adam
are you high usually they don't allow
special effects makeup artists that much
time to prep but I said no wait we've
got to have you know months and months
and months to to get anywhere close to
something that can work here because
it's it's the movement you know thank
God you know we've had people who were
patient enough with me to just kind of
keep going and keep going and keep going
until eventually going all right I think
I think we're in the realm a wonderful
experience working you know with Adam he
uses a mic and we'll kind of just Chuck
out lines and Chuck out ideas and try
saying this instead not improvising but
like you know suggesting lines and
nudging you in the right direction but
you've got to be prepared to Pivot and
be on your toes even though Cheney's
very not somebody who you would think of
as being on his toes he's very much like
flat-foot but yeah and I really enjoyed
uh the immersion that that took you know
even though it was like the four hours
in the chair and whatnot I'd never
believed that it could be possible that
I could play him and to to give it a
shot he's just a was a wonderful risk
you have authorization to shoot down any
aircraft deemed a threat presidential
Authority that is correct all the orders
are uniteer unity unless otherwise
directed Mr Vice President are we sure
these are the proper Rules of Engagement
the country is under attack the Roe is
fluid well he was very brilliant you
know he is he is a brilliant man you
know he whether you agree with what he
his intent you know was and is his
absolute Brilliance in intelligence
there you know he rose incredibly
quickly for good reason he he understood
the Machinery of um of politics uh
better than anyone else did and so he
could manipulate that and for someone
who was absolutely awful a lot of retail
politics you know he had no interest in
kissing babies or whatever he was very
interested in the true mechanics of
power and and how that works in his is
nobody better at it than him
part of the Sun
[Music]
[Applause]
man what an adventure yeah it was
something else I got to not go to school
and travel about by myself and I had no
idea just how unique that experience was
at the time because I didn't realize
that every film didn't build a bloody
Runway the planes could land on in the
middle of a Marshland in Spain or build
a pagoda or build a you know huge
hospital to build literally half a
full-size Stadium out there I didn't
realize every film didn't travel to
China and have you know 10 000 extras up
and down the Bund you know it wasn't
until later when I was on much smaller
films I went oh yeah hang on that was a
big one which I think was great in that
way because I didn't really feel any
pressure and at that age I didn't really
feel like uh an actual film was going to
come out of it at the end I was just in
the moment doing it animals and children
are the best actors you can't compete
with them and the reason is because they
don't give a [ __ ] about the consequences
and in many ways that was how I felt
when I was making a part of the sun you
know not through any intentional thing
it just didn't even enter my mind b29
yeah the super Fortress what we call a
hemisphere defense weapon
Okinawa Philippines Tokyo is in bombing
range now time to think of going home
soon there's a great Purity to just
playing a role and that's it because
every kid does it every every kid I
still consider that I play dress-up for
a living you know and kids do that
naturally it only gets spoiled when
adults come in and ruin it by bringing
money and expectations and you should do
more Etc that's when things go wrong I
never felt that while I was filming
you know I mean there were times because
I left my family Etc they weren't able
to come with me so I you know I'd be
like in the airport you know crying my
eyes out going I don't want to go but
when I got there man I was loving it and
I was enjoying it no end but then it was
it was when I started doing the Press I
didn't get that I couldn't understand
that and I didn't understand why I had
to keep talking about the same thing all
day long and that was it was starting to
go insane and then people follow me
around or whatever and so that was when
I went oh no this isn't this isn't for
me but I always focused on going yeah
but I really did love doing it itself so
let's try to figure it out so I can deal
with this part of it and not uh have to
stop doing the bit that I really do
enjoy there's a price for everything and
it's a it's a once you get your head
around it it's a very small price to pay
for getting to sell uh stories and I
recognize and I'm so grateful for what I
do get to to do
Amsterdam
how can I know this is you really in the
picture
uh yes sir so well I'm the doctor she's
the nurse she's the attorney we all met
in Belgium which if you were College
where we met for the first time it's
about someone who's in experimental
medicine and likewise so with his brace
you know it's something that he hates
but he can't be without because he's got
such terrible injuries you know to his
back and his spine and everything like
that so no I just kept on all the time
because you'll see you see it through
the the suit you know it's kind of like
two little bumps of the metal sticking
out you know and and if I can avoid
acting I do avoid acting like if you can
just really do it and be uncomfortable
why bother pretending to be
uncomfortable just be uncomfortable it
was a practical thing because you know
these these were very rudimentary back
braces not like anything you would get
today these were things that he had kind
of made himself in the same way that
he's working on creating medicine that
can help these returning war vets who
weren't given a damn bit of help you
know they were meant to be returning
Heroes and absolutely nobody treated him
like that it was Despicable men who were
all suffering from PTSD but nobody
recognized that
um a tool and these terrible terrible
injuries but didn't have the right
painkillers or anxiety pills or whatever
David and I we wanted to create
um characters that we loved that we
wanted to hang out with characters that
just refused to be beaten down by life
despite everything that life had thrown
at them that they remained optimistic
refused to be cynical whatsoever I brows
up was kind of our Mantra where is my
eye Harold
right here
you leave me here with this invalid when
you know very well that I think she
should be hospitalized it's for her own
good I do remember that both of them
looked a bit shell-shocked on the very
first day of work because they hadn't
worked with David before we'll film The
Script but then he will just throw
different lines of people or he'll just
change the lines no don't you say that
you're going to say that now and he'll
be laying on the floor underneath here
and they know cruel during the scene
over there and then he'll be up behind
the camera over here and then he'll just
say change everything and go do that and
I love it but David would occasionally
come to me when he saw someone was just
sort of looking like a deer calling
headlights and say oh can you go be the
ambassador and just explain how we're
going to do this and then everyone got
into it and then it's really joyful and
and just a very very satisfying
experience so Margo and JD just embraced
it you know and then I would go off and
you know I'd telephone him and go sound
like a stalker but I'd be like there's a
dude I'm following down the street oh my
God he's fantastic I'm going to use this
for Bernie's like great and then I tell
him that mannerisms from different
people attitudes you know it was all
kind of very baked in and over years so
it was wonderful about that is that by
the time you're actually filming it's
really in your bones
pale blue eye
there's so many good actors I tell you
lately I've been so blessed with the
different amount of talented actors I've
gone to work with and so it was a real
pleasure to work with all them but let
me just focus on one and that would be
Harry melling because Harry is just a
really superb actor and so I just I just
enjoyed any day that we got to do scenes
Together Scott Cooper and I have worked
together now this is our third film
I love working with Scott and this was
something that we've been talking about
since like uh 2012 that he had been put
together he is prolific beyond belief in
terms of his writing he went and did
different things I went and did
different things but just the period of
it uh the gothic uh sort of crime
um nature of it the sort of uh fun
origin story of Edgar Allan Poe and what
might have made him into such a master
of the Macabre and why he was so
comfortable and enjoyed that way of
thinking and trying to think about okay
well what what let's create a character
that could have inspired all of that and
that also keeps in the vein of an Edgar
Allan Poe story itself as well so and I
think so Scottsdale a superb job again
with that